je ne prends pas de voir un sujet
justement sur les travaux qui sont faits
sur le parcours de l'albatros en vue de
l'accueil de la ryder cup en 2018 la
ryder cup 2018 se prépare dès maintenant
au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines d'importants
travaux de rénovation ont été entrepris
sur le parcours de l'albatros depuis le
16 juillet dernier pour accueillir la
coupe du monde du golf
plus d'une centaine d'ouvriers
jardiniers ont investi les greens pour
améliorer les 18 trous et l'accueil du
public
là on aura travaillé à petites
améliorations sur des greens ou sur des
départs pour que vraiment les sportifs
puissent s'exprimer au mieux mais on a
aussi beaucoup travaillé pour la qualité
de l'accueil du public en faisant des
routes des plateformes qui vont
permettre au public de circuler de voir
le golf le bas fond on a une chance et
qu'on peut aller au plus près des
athlètes aéro plus près des sportifs
pour les voir donc
et on sait qu'on aura énormément de
public ici les 200000 spectateurs
attendus à guyancourt pour la ryder cup
pourront également observé un parcours
plus visuel avec une dizaine de nouveaux
bon coeur mais point d'eau vont
également être créés sur le site
il ya eu des changements et un
changement déjà dû ans parce que c'était
un trou qui manquait un peu de caractère
et on avait besoin d'un endroit pour
stocker de l'eau déjà de bonnes raisons
pour le faire
et puis les deux autres changements qui
vont être marqués sur le green du 1 et
le green du 16 mai qui ont été rendus
plus juste pour le joueur mais aussi
plus facile à gérer lors d'un gros
événement
voilà donc sinon il n'y a pas de
changement notoire
déjà c'est difficile les travaux de
rénovation devrait s'achever en avril
2016 les golfeurs pourront jouer à
nouveau sur l'albatros à partir de
décembre
mais ce sera sur un parcours réduit avec
seulement neuf trous bonjour à tous les
trois alors mustapha larbaoui bonjour
président du football-club rap et yves
jean de l'année 1 vous avez été élu lino
de l'année ce pas c'est pas rien c'est à
nos courtiers de la fédération française
de cyclisme
bonsoir et philippe il a tout du golf
national or on vient de voir on va
peut-être commencer par vous puisque je
viens de voir sur ce sujet
ça implique beaucoup de travaux
d'accueillir la ryder cup parce que le
parcours et était déjà formidable mais
évidemment il faut quoi accueillir du
public que le rendent plus plus simple
et difficile
le parcours mon sens patrice bien en
fait la ryder cup ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que c'est un gros événement c'est
le troisième événement sportif le plus
suivi après les jeux olympiques et la
coupe du monde de football donc c'est
beaucoup de visibilité c'est
effectivement beaucoup de spectateurs
parce qu'on s'attend à accueillir
près de 250 mille spectateurs sur sur
trois jours et effectivement par rapport
à cela il ya un aspect d'accueil ou en
créer par le biais des travaux des
routes pour pouvoir faire passer les
spectateurs des zones d'hospitalité où
on est en train de créer près de trente
mille mètres carrés de zone
d'hospitalité il ya le deuxième penchant
qui en fait qui est la partie parcours
où on a fait de gros travaux on va dire
sous terre avec des travaux de drainage
des travaux d'arrosage de drainage
pourquoi parce qu'en fait il faut qu'on
soit en capacité de pouvoir faire tenir
le tournoi sur les trois journées qui
nous seront données et ce tournoi va se
dérouler sur le premier week-end du mois
d'octobre de l'année 2018
donc si on a de fortes pluies il faut
quand même que les joueurs puissent
quand même voilà pratiquer et conçois
pas qu'on fasse pas comme ça s'est
déroulé au caltech manor au pays de
galles qu'on ne repousse pas le tournoi
le dernier tour sur la journée du lundi
et après le troisième voilà le troisième
point c'est il ya eu effectivement comme
le disait le directeur du golf des
travaux sur le côté un peu esthétique on
à reconfigurer certains green en à
reconfigurer certains trous qui ont
vraiment un aspect beaucoup plus
challenging on va dire et voilà on a
beaucoup travaillé là-dessus pour un
voilà je suis pour ce qui est déjà
beaucoup de monde qui vient voir du
monde entier dans le parcours de golf
national bat actuellement en étant
partiellement l'arrière travaux mais
alors on est on est très sollicités
c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup de demandes
de joueurs étrangers on l'a vu avant la
fermeture du parcours le parcours
affirmé le 19 juillet de l'année 2015 et
on a vu avant la fermeture du parcours
en engouement extraordinaire de joueurs
qui venaient avec des italiens des
espagnols des américains ça devenait
vraiment à travers le monde et des
asiatiques aussi qu'ils venaient
beaucoup joué sur le site
et là on a beaucoup de demandes
pour la réouverture du parcours tu es là
vraiment à partir du 1er mai parce que
c'est la date officielle d'ouverture du
parcours le parcours sera plat ça va
être compliqué et il va y va être ouvert
jusqu'à quand je pense que jusqu'à la
ryder cup où il est ferme et 2,2 à
fermer un an ou deux mois pour dire non
en fait ce qui va se passer c'est que
normalement il devrait fermer un mois
avant la ryder cup d'ailleurs qui
devrait fermer le mois de septembre
précédent 2018 précédent la ryder cup de
façon à le préparer au mieux pour
l'accueil des 24 meilleurs joueurs
mondiaux
et après ils ferment on a la chance
également d'accueillir chaque année
l'open de france qui est également un
tournoi qui sera qui sera là c'est à
dire évidemment oui cette année en plus
et une sur le nouveau parcours donc sur
le parcours de l'art et dire que pareil
ça sera la première fois qu'on joue à
deux le parcours dans la configuration
valley ryder cup et en plus c'est une
année un peu particulière parce que
c'est c'est la centième c'est le
centième open de france et il faut
rappeler que l'open de france c'est le
plus vieux tournoi d'europe continentale
donc il ya une vraie culture golf en
france est un vieux sport pratiqué en
france et donc 100e open de france donc
en plus avec des voilà des points plus
important pour les joueurs donc on y
avec des joueurs classés qui peuvent
gagner et ce qu'ils qui écope du
blizzard on a des joueurs français les
ont gagné et on a des joueurs français
qui voient là il faut il faut rappeler
qu'on a quand même 14 joueurs français
qui jouent bas au top sur le circuit
européen non comme à 14 joueurs donc on
a quatorze potentielle mais effective et
non on a donc quelques uns seront
peut-être dans l'équipe de la ryder cup
en tout cas on à victor dubuisson qui
était et qui était à gleneagles en 2001
il ya deux ans et là maintenant cette
année on a encore victor qui était dans
les points pour preuve voilà pour faire
partie des équipes tout à fait et sur le
sur l'ailé les habitants du territoire
est ce que vous sentez comme ça on
engouement qui montrent que que cette
annonce de la ryder cup a provoqué nos
vies de venir voir de venir se
renseigner de savoir ce qu'est le golf
peut-être de jouer
alors pour l'instant on n'a pas encore
énormément que de communication à ce
niveau là sur le sur la ryder cup mais
ensemble on a les maires qui nous
sollicitent et ça je trouve ça très bien
déjà en amont de façon à justement
sensibiliser
les chefs de cabinet les membres des
mairies à ce que va être la ryder cup et
je pense que par ce biais là on sera si
chaque mairie fait ce travail de
communication auprès des auprès des
riverains on aura on aura vraiment un
vrai intérêt parce que si la russie
d'aredor cup passe bien évidemment par
une bonne organisation du tournoi mais
je pense que si ça doit passer par un
engouement et par une participation des
riverains à la fête et à cette fête du
golfe et après on voit on a organisé en
des journées portes ouvertes notamment
avec la communauté d'agglomération avec
on a jumelé ça avec les journées du
patrimoine est en fait on s'est rendu
compte qu'on a eu beaucoup de personnes
et et de locaux qui venait pour se
renseigner sur ce qu'était le golf
national donc on sent effectivement
patrice une gourmande et add on va dire
des riverains proches sur le golf la
ryder cup est peut-être pas encore mais
déjà le golf c'est déjà pas mal
discovery a besoin de gens qui viennent
vous aidé de bénévoles par exemple les
bénévoles il va falloir beaucoup de
bénévoles effectivement parce que la
ryder cup comme je le disais tout à
l'heure c'est ces deux cent cinquante
mille spectateurs sur sur six journées
on va dire il ya trois journées de
tournoi mais après derrière les journées
d'entraînement donc on peut même aller
un petit peu plus loin donc il va
falloir effectivement des bénévoles et
les bénévoles ça va être des bénévoles
ce qui est intéressant c'est que j'ai eu
la chance d'aller à gleneagles et des
bénévoles même des causes disait comment
est ce qu'on fait pour venir vous aider
à y participer à la fête et la grande
fête du golfe donc on aura besoin de
besoin de bénévoles oui tout à fait ardo
courtier alors vous n'êtes pas très loin
à la fédération française de robes ya eu
les championnats du monde en 2015 qui
est un souvenir formidable 2016 ça va
être en principe aussi une baladé dans
le cyclisme
oui ça va être une belle année en tout
cas on y travaille effectivement en 2015
on a eu des championnats du monde et si
bien de le rappeler parce que ces
championnats du monde ont été organisées
seulement un an après l'ouverture du
vélodrome tout neuf exactement et
ça nous a permis de démontrer qu'ils
étaient neufs est parfaitement
opérationnel
on a accueilli des cyclistes de haut
niveau des champions du monde entier des
records du monde qui sont tombés sur
cette piste qui donc en un événement a
pu faire sa réputation sportive des
athlètes français qui ont performé cinq
médailles d'or dans ces championnats du
monde
et puis surtout ça a été la première
véritable rencontre en fait du public et
particulièrement du public saint
quentinois avec ce vélodrome qui est un
véritable symbole de performance mais
aussi de communication de lien social
pour ces événements sportifs mais aussi
culturels professionnels qui sont
organisés et saha je pense contribuer
largement effectivement à la venue
régulière quotidienne du public des
abonnés qui viennent faire pratiquer la
piste mais aussi les autres activités
sportives qui sont organisés que ce soit
du badminton de la gym enfin il ya pas
mal de choses vélodrome donc 2015 une
année importante qui nous a permis
d'installer c'était ce vélodrome sur le
territoire de saint quentin et au niveau
national bien sûr et internationales et
internationale est on est on est plutôt
content de ce qui s'est passé c'était un
vrai succès donc pas envie d'y retourner
donc nous travaillons d'arrache-pied
avec le soutien de saint quentin en
yvelines à accueillir en octobre si tout
se passe bien du 19 au 23 octobre 2016
les championnats d'europe de cyclisme
sur piste donc la même chose un petit
peu moins deux pays
mais normalement un très très bel
événement à la fin de l'année alors
philippe inattendu disais voilà pour le
goff s'il ya des gens qui viennent voir
la brède le golf c'est peut-être un
petit peu comme ça plus éloigné que tu
réellement que le vélo le lever l'europe
50 ha c'est évidemment un pôle
d'excellence avec ces championnats avec
des champions mais c'est tout le monde
peut y venir et tout le monde y
viendrons absolument tout le monde peut
y venir tout le monde y vient on a la
poussière à quoi a dit oui il ya aussi
la piste olympique de bmx
c'est important de le rappeler et on a
toutes les semaines des baptêmes on peut
s'inscrire conception n'a jamais fait
par suler monde vélo de compétition dort
ou tout autre on peut s'inscrire on peut
venir découvrir la piste que ce soit du
bmx ou que ce soit la piste du vélodrome
on peut s'initier et puis si ça vous
plaît on peut revenir après on peut
s'abonner on peut venir pédaler en fin
de compte tous les jours il ya des
sessions ouvertes au public avec des
groupes de niveaux de débutant à
confirmé pour tous les âges on peut
d'aller tous ensemble c'est le point
commun du cyclisme du golfe finalement
c'est que oui ça qu'on pratique et on
peut pédaler en famille entre amis comme
comme pour le golf qu'on peut pratiquer
dans les mêmes conditions si je vous
demandais un pourcentage de chance
d'avoir le championnat d'europe vous
pourriez en dira oui je m'en diras gérer
99.9 ouais c'est pas ce n'est pas encore
officiel s'est pas totalement validé on
est en train de boucler le budget mais
on sait très bien engagée vous allez
faire du vélo posteriori dont je rends
en réalité j'essaie de trouver
maintenant le point comment qu'ils ont
un point commun entre eux ont été
détruits pour le pool est roi c'est que
voilà en tous les cas nous dans la
pratique du football
on essaye détendre également la pratique
un d'autres sports parce que les choses
sont très complémentaires
donc le vélo bien évidemment surtout en
début de saison on a besoin de courir on
a besoin de décrasser on a besoin de
relancer la machine en en tout début de
saison donc le vélo on le pratique et
concernant le golfe
il est prévu d initiation et il ya déjà
des projets en cours pour faire
découvrir ce type seulement voilà je
pense que la transversalité au niveau
des sports que ça se passe à tort
d'ailleurs où la culture
bah c'est important parce qu'on a on a
beaucoup parlé tout à l'heure de
macroéconomie on est dans l'est dans la
micro économie mais on est sur le
terrain on est sur le terrain de sport
vision de terry est et ce qui nous
importe c'est quand même de que nos
enfants c'est le découvrir des sports de
la culture et en même temps voilà que
s'ils quittent eu la moindre structure
qu'il ne se déstructure pas et la
déstructuration et e.on et justement
j'ai du tissu social
je disais que vous avez été désigné
comme yvelinois de l'année mais c'est
par hasard c'est à dire que c'est pas
seulement pour les résultats du football
club de trappes
c'est parce que non vous fait un
formidable travail avec le sport et
grâce au sport d'éducation vis-à-vis des
enfants les avis des jeunes à la trappe
dans la région de trappes et c'est ça
qui est aussi sociale va le sport c'est
évidemment la performance
on va voir des grands champions ça se
trouvaient deux drôles que ce soit au
golf national
mais on a aussi et c'était aussi une
façon d'éduquer les jeunes c'est ce que
c'est au fond c'est ça votre votre notre
particularité
merci merci patrice
merci patrice surtout de pouvoir parler
et finalement de des actions qu'on mène
sur les territoires les territoires
comme ceux de trappes
essentiellement ce que c'est là qu'on
agit avec le nettoie les sportifs de
trappes
mais alors pour revenir sur le livre
noir c'est parce qu'on a un bon réseau
parce qu'après tout ça reste un club de
plus de me licencier donc beaucoup de
votants probablement plus de vingt ans
pour le club de foot bilan vous le
méritez que pour éventuellement les
restaurateurs ou autres personnes qui
ont pu avoir un réseau un peu plus un
peu moins construit un peu moins fourni
donc c'est pas la performance c'est
effectivement avoir été choisi d'abord
par les nouvelles de versailles choisi
parce que beaucoup d'actions sont menées
sur ce territoire mais en réalité pour
sur le département
oui c'est vrai que au delà du sport
voilà il ya une vraie vraie vocation
nous avons tous
toute l'équipe une vraie vocation à
voile à élever le débat
par exemple on a été salué pour la mise
en place de l'académie alors
pompeusement appelée l'académie c'est ni
plus ni moins que des classes de renfort
de renforts d' en maths et en français
donc on fait le ramassage scolaire de
toutes les écoles du territoire dans la
ville de trappes précisément et après
l'école après une journée complète on
l'est on va les chercher en bus ont
leurs prêts on leur propose un goûter
goûter qui rarement nous pourrait
prendre six étaient chez eux
clairement c'est eux qui le disent et
après on fait du renfort maths français
et ensuite on enchaîne à l'école est
souvent la question nous est posée quel
rapport
finalement ces classes quel rapport avec
le sport quel rapport avec le foot
bahia un rapport déjà c'est que le
football est issu des london school le
football et issus des grandes écoles qui
ont permis au départ c'est voilà c'est
bien le gouvernement
le rugby lyon d'autres sports j'ai pas
étudié les autres mais clairement le
sport le football en particulier c'est
plutôt les berges et je crois bien avant
oui ça vient de belize
voilà des deux grandes écoles les élites
les on a parlé tout à l'heure de deux
pôles de deux pôles
comment dire d'excellence
à saint quentin et probablement qu'au
travers du football en particulier c'est
celui que je pratique mais probablement
d'autres sports et d'autres éléments de
la culture
il ya moyen également de produire des
choses en tout cas de contribuer à
l'élitisme mais pas simplement pour
avoir des élites mais aussi pour
contribuer à élever le débat et surtout
sur les notions éducatif donc oui le
football c'est ça c'est vulgariser
depuis cette époque c'est juste pour
éviter la vulgarité maintenant qu'on
essaie de revenir en essayant de muscler
bas les fibres les fibres pour le coup
musculaire mais il ya également le tissu
tissus nerveux et la matière grise donc
on essaye d'avoir des complémentarités
par le biais du football qui n'est
jamais qu'un prétexte
sachant que nos enfants qu'ils aiment le
foot mais on leur ment pas on leur dit
pas que c'est qu'une activité un jeu ou
un loisir
on leur dit clairement on est là pour
jouer on est là pour s'amuser on est là
pour apprendre
mais clairement aussi pour vivre
ensemble et la pression se mettre en
place mais normand pas on leur dit
justement on parlait tout à l'heure avec
les élus des baisses de dotations
est ce que c'est quelque chose que de
que vous sentez-vous dont vous souffrez
est-ce que voilà parce que vous avez
besoin évidemment d'un d'argent pour
faire ce rôle et du catch sportif et
éducatif
clairement les élus ont en ont parlé
sa part de rouyn sa part d'en haut il ya
des décisions qui sont en haut et
finalement on est descendu jusqu'au
niveau des collectivités locales et nous
nous sommes encore plus au souci du
terrain puisque par définition nous
sommes les associations oui clairement
j'ai perdu j'ai perdu plus de 23000
euros de subventions ce qui représente
plus de 15% du budget c'est énorme
les élus l'ont dit tout alors que
c'était que le sale alors un niveau
salle les deux temps plus aux nôtres
surtout qu'on essaye d'apporter plus
encore avec beaucoup moins de moyens
l'académie par exemple elle seule est
autofinancé donc on est passé par le
problème parler parler les emplois
civique et puis on fait des économies
dans le club de la même façon mais au
delà des baisses de subventions ce qui
moi ce qui me gêne le plus finalement
c'est d'abord c'est de bien connaître la
règle c'est important pour nous c'est
comme il est chaque fois repris
ces règles et reynès et qu'on s'y
tiennent donc une fois c'est la
compétence des uns une fois c'est pas la
compétence des autres on y comprend pas
tout à fait c'est pas très clair mais
une fois que une fois qu on comprend
bien ce qu'on nous dit on fait avec
donc d'une part un problème de
clarification de compétences alors moi
j'ai cru comprendre que la communauté
d'agglomération s'était pas sa
compétence au niveau des clubs comme les
nôtres mais que c'était de la compétence
au niveau du sport ville de sport
d'élite et on parlait tout à l'heure du
golfe et et du vélo on sait maintenant
donc on se rabat sur la compétence
communale
mais ce qui me gênerait encore plus
c'est le fait qu'ils aient probablement
pas suffisamment d'évaluation de ces
deniers publics dans nos collectivités
et aux associations
alors cessez saupoudré je vois bien
qu'il ya des intérêts à mon avis de
vouloir donner à tout le monde
la volonté encore une fois de satisfaire
tout le monde je ne sais pas comment
s'évaluer je sais pas comment ça
fonctionne parce que quand on se
retrouve bon on comprend pas bien et
c'est de ça dont j'avais plus besoin
c'est qu'on vienne nous voir plus
souvent convient d'évaluer ce qu'on fait
qu'on vienne nous aider tout simplement
dans l'accompagnement je parle même pas
d'argent
ardo courtier ça fait quoi ça fait
combien de temps que la fédération et
saint quentin
la fédération est à saint quentin depuis
l'inauguration du vélodrome sur lequel
est installé donc depuis le 1er janvier
vous êtes content on ne regrettait pas
will n'avons pas du tout une journée
particulièrement contents ils vont
encore parce qu'on est installé au coeur
même du vélodrome qui est un outil
formidable
donc on est très content d'être là on
est très content parce qu'on est sur un
territoire dynamique au niveau du tissu
économique au niveau du de la volonté
sportive en atteste la présence du golf
national du vélodrome nationale et je
voudrais ajouter par rapport à ce qui
vient d'être dit et sur les aspects
économiques c'est important de le dire
que les grands événements que nous
organisons comme des championnats du
monde comme championnat d'europe comme
va l'être la ryder cup sont des
événements qui certes coûte de l'argent
à produire bien évidemment même si
aujourd'hui on
on les produits manière très raisonnée
on est très prudent mais c'est aussi
pendant l'événement à l'issue de
l'événement des retombées économiques
très importantes sur le territoire on a
à coeur de travailler avec des
entreprises de saint quentin en yvelines
a travaillé avec des saint quentinois à
tous les niveaux et ce sont évidemment
des retombées économiques pour les
restaurateurs pour les autres pour les
hôtels tout pour tous tous les gens qui
vont travailler pendant ces événements
et c'est assez notable philippe lattaud
évidemment il ya le 29 ans mais la ryder
cup ça va être pour tous les hôteliers
main de toute la région je suppose que
ça va être évidemment formidable enfin
un événement économique aussi quoi
weaver l'événement économique est
effectivement par rapport à cela ça va
être formidable parce que par rapport au
volume de personnes que ça va toucher ce
qu'il faut c'est quand même se
représenter que pendant pendant
pratiquement une semaine en or à
l'équivalent d'un stade de france qui
reviendra sur / sur la ville depuis en
cours tout cas sur le site du off
nationale et après par rapport à cela
bien évidemment savoir des retombées sur
tout ce qui peut voir aussi c'est que ça
va on va avoir une énorme visibilité sur
le sur le territoire parce que c'est sa
touche c'est à pratiquement 1 milliard
et demi de téléspectateurs c'est 185
pays qui vont être touchés par l'arrêt
leur club donc en plus des retombées
bien évidemment économique il va y avoir
c'est cette notion de visibilité qui en
suit permettra de pouvoir continuer
justement à faire en sorte à ce que le
sitv parce que le but du jeu c'est qu'on
a à la ryder cup mais le but du jeu
c'est de continuer à faire vivre le site
et notamment le golf national
après cette ryder cup et c'est ce qui
est vraiment très très challenging on va
dire par rapport à par rapport à cela
quoi il est impatiente d'arriver à 2018
où on est on est plus que dans les
starting blocks on a commencé à démarrer
la course mais le boulot ouais c'est du
travail mais c'est un travail
exceptionnel cirque c'est participer à l
événement golfique planétaire le plus
voilà le plus prestigieux donc par
rapport à ça on a une équipe qui est
derrière on avait quitté motiver les
collaborateurs sur le terrain qui
travaille justement là
à l'amélioration de la qualité du
parcours sont vraiment très très
impliquée par rapport à cela parce que
c'est quelque chose qu'on vivra qu'une
seule fois des lois driggs au delà de ça
on a quand même une notion de
développement du sport développement du
golf on a comme le disait tout à l'heure
mustapha on travaille également au golf
national de façon à bas par rapport à la
mixité ont fait venir des jeunes issus
de milieux défavorisés via la fondation
lacoste de façon voilà qui fait un
travail formidable qui fait un travail
formidable le but du jeu c'est vraiment
de faire découvrir ce sport à des jeunes
qui seraient jamais venus d'eux mêmes
voilà le pratiquer merci beaucoup à tous
les trois et beaux bons championnats
d'europe on va dire qu'ils sont là
pratiquement